well my husband and I got engaged and
and I had already done a movie with
George Clooney Solaris and I also did
far from heaven which is a movie he
produced with Steven Soderbergh so at
the premiere far from heaven
I had my engagement ring and I said and
he said oh well I bought a villa and I'm
like wow and he said you need to go to
my villa for your honeymoon and I said
oh my god are you serious
you're really serious right you're
serious and he said I'm serious I'm not
like one of those Hollywood people that
says let's add larger then we never have
lunch and so I hounded him about that
villa and he literally sent a car to
pick me my husband up in Milan and we
were the only guests in his 22-room
villa four or five course meals I talk
about it all the time like but I I'm
telling you it's like the greatest gift
anyone could have given us I mean it was
so romantic so generous of him because
it it's not like me and George hang out
you know I mean I like the guy but well
you know from just doing all the
publicity for this movie I have just
found my voice I have been you know it's
like I said before you know I'm a
theater geek I went to theater school
which is so much about pleasing your
teachers and creating a performance that
that's right you know it's got to be
right it's got to be dead-on and so when
I when I started getting all this
scrutiny for making the choice of
playing a maid you know in the deep
south who was had a broken dialect I was
taken aback at first but through the
course of having to defend my choices
I've really found my voice you know
which really parallels a Bolin's life
that at some point you have to stand up
to your convictions and know that you're
going to have
whether the storms not everyone is gonna
like you we live in we are in a very
subjective profession and art form where
anything could hit someone and offend
them at the same time please them you
have no idea but um the only thing you
could do at the end of the day is is is
have a voice and I found mine you know
thank God you know it's like 46 years
old you would think it took a long time
finally